Michael Brown okay we're back we're back
we're going for a [ __ ] Calabasas and
that little whining [ __ ] I can tell
where I guess what the [ __ ] hat oh
okay where am I [ __ ] now um I gotta
find grant Lockwood he's [ __ ] out
here still where is he
Lockwood Mosley vacuum oh [ __ ]
okay so I'm not your guy
nice [ __ ] bodies out here somewhere
okay okay calm down okay hardware labs
try it star hook it sorry
[Music]
how do I get that medicine oh [ __ ]
oh I know where it is [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
oh you make me so mad sometimes how the
[ __ ] do I get out of here
how the [ __ ] do I get out of here oh
okay oh [ __ ] I see it I see it I see it
[ __ ] horses we're just going all the
way here forgive me Jesus
okay okay we got it
hey got it
coming in hot but [ __ ] it [ __ ] it Oh
you again doctor you worry [ __ ] where's
that little snowing Kon Aires diagnosing
looks like you've had a rough day
yeah thank you a lot of patient
experience questionnaire so I can serve
you better next time Oh God Morgan you
surprised
hey you know what I got back please
right at the neck yes
look for the large yes sir it was harder
when I was doing it myself
that second [ __ ] and checking NATO oh
god I can breathe again and feel my legs
Esther some spots lie but OSHA clear ah
thanks Marcus
and it's a nice work model you'll make
junior engineer yes now yet to the lift
might be careful no telling what got
stirred up in the shake awesome you can
see you at your office
okay now level now what's the [ __ ]
commissioner
I wondered how you would react to
finding Michaela you risk your life to
help her i dad makes me think the
neurosurgeon didn't erase everything nor
school lately perhaps particularly
strong memories still leave faint
impressions intuitive feelings or maybe
you're simply more compassionate than I
expected
are you sure it wouldn't have been
better to I don't mean to be insensitive
but when she finds out you intend to
destroy tell us one she might react
strongly given that there's no way off
the station Agnes hello are you here for
an appointment now warning singles level
window lock off the campus we evacuate
I'd avoid all open flames or spice until
repairs can be made okay how do I
where's the [ __ ]
warning dangerous level of explosive gas
detected please evacuate and avoid all
open flames or sparks until repairs can
be many mornings dangerous love Ornan
dangers of explosive golf detected we
evacuate I'd avoid all over the place or
sides he calls me I want a [ __ ]
pummel this ass she coming up
okay SPECT elapsed apart I guess oh we
get that lift that we [ __ ] which app
that okay it's going crazy it's getting
real weird right
[Music]
you came back and from outside sixth
elevators thank you
now it can move free you not so much
you are in less word a joke there I
think you tanks warrior trust our food
comes from chopped up and made new
colors correcting the septic system a
jungle to I think that this
[Music]
like a fan are you gonna do that oh yeah
I shall take my thing with me yeah I'm
taking nothing with me
[Applause]
where is [ __ ]
with online checking birthdays servers
offline
okay I'm [ __ ] losing it [ __ ]
[Applause]
ah-ah-ah-ah
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I guess not Jesus
your office look I guess I see where all
that transfer money goes [ __ ] [ __ ] I
guess I see where all that France our
money goes GP Lee uses your life AJ you
made it
chief engineer illusion what the hell
Morgan you sir
no no that's easily in January Morgan
used personal operator
how about loving the sound of your own
voice so it's the three of us four of us
anyone else from the labs or
psychotronics it's not Morgan forks
station at the top akita chief ill you
should please do not working copy shop
normal endo he'll be no winner of the
employee duties
ah okay hard worried him oh yeah [ __ ] I
was there before what's he doing here
Bobby [ __ ] a patient award this course
holy [ __ ] where's my office sign and I
taste that flow'd sales division your
office
this is the craziest thing I've ever
seen
[Applause]
okay well if I'm gonna do it I bet I
have a [ __ ] map y'all love [ __ ]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] I'm [ __ ] for help
oh it's the three or four of us anyone
else from the labs or psychotronics it's
got Morgan Fork station and fabricator
chief Ellucian please do not copy me you
shot one is everyone's responsibility
then all hope reflecto concurrency
security a scorecard chatter - any help
[Music]
[Music]
holy [ __ ] okay I just I guess I just
cannot do that oh it's the three oh okay
four of us anyone else from the laughs
or psychotronics if not Morgan Fork
station and fabricator gee Phil you
should please do not like it
Tapia you shot loss of office through
gravity or other theories emerge big
favor for the year plus decision
please don't be crazy
so I'll be crazy
oh um it's just the nuts it's just the
nuts actually
and I don't [ __ ] have any food or
anything look at that and I'm sending
you the code to my grass yeah assuming
is to work already already in there
[Applause]
see Charlie went back up huh maybe I can
help you I won't be Joe your [ __ ]
[ __ ] don't worry there's no trick
just a gift from your big brother it's
the truth I took promise come in a while
to digital well so I wanted to hide it
from you my computer another video yep
good luck and we'll talk I'm sending you
the password assuming you haven't hacked
your way in yet okay where is it
that's [ __ ]
here's it you've auto-ship you can't
move it
my name is Morgan you here is 2035 I'm
aboard the talus one research facility
what else why are we making this video
right because my Big Brother's paranoid
psychometric data is showing
statistically significant variance and
personality patterns between trial runs
or the new neural mods whatever I feel
more like myself than ever I mean look
at this we did it out it's real enjoy it
while you can because in a few minutes
that will all be gone when we strip out
the neural robots and we said I know
including my memory of it no way around
it
let's talk about the backup so the type
and organisms have been produced an
elaborate structure material is unknown
purpose unknown now my gut tells me it's
a kind of neural framework but
externalized still waiting on analysis
to confirm in the meantime I've given
Alex the design for a device I think
could shut it down if it ever broke
containment Alex just have to grow up
here and commit you know that to take
all credit she said what if it doesn't
work it'll work
trust me to hear what else we going to
do blow everything up that won't save us
and if it does work because it wasn't
the people that come after us we'll be
smarter stronger immortal they can judge
us if they want but they'll know they
exist because of the things we did I'm
ready
do it
why is he taking the [ __ ] out of brain
is that my skull are you havin
everything I've done that's what you've
asked me to do I didn't think you'd
believe me unless you heard it from your
own mouth the test they changed you a
lot of first but eventually the constant
stripping of your memory I didn't know
who you are anymore all I want is it
have my brother back so we can finish
what we started the device you mentioned
it's an advanced version of the null way
it's the only way to stop the typhoon
without destroying everything we've been
working toward we're just missing some
scanned data from the Carl to complete
the design help me finish this Morgan
and then you can have my arming key I
don't believe if you want to use it
anymore but you can have it
I love the chipset for you on my desk
you'll need to upgrade your psycho scope
to scan the Carl I'll send you the Scan
locations okay get the chip set for
scanning coral from Alex doesn't install
it
[ __ ] is that how do we [ __ ] upgrade
my suit thing
as an act for
okay
[ __ ] energy nap up
and okay
stamina now combat focused now
just [ __ ] looking at again what is
this
and I [ __ ] get more slot
psychotronics what the [ __ ]
now what have enough for that anyway
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay so we'll just [ __ ]
do this [ __ ] inventories bigger okay I
did it
what I say Waimea wow this whole thing's
[ __ ] on a kiss back complete okay I
guess we're really going to do this
[Music]
Morgan
that video was I'm still checking it
against my directives but as scanning
the coral will grant you access to
Alex's arming key then perhaps it's the
best course perhaps knowing the corals
purpose will reinforce your decision to
destroy Talos one just be careful
yeah yeah yeah run out time is it what a
suck it dick if we get it wet okay
Michael brother I've been thinking about
the video Alex showed you your brother
believes that version of you is the true
Morgan but why just because it came
first if someone had made you then I
suppose your truest self would be the
one that fulfills whatever purpose your
maker intended I know who made me and
why did someone make you Morgan were you
made for something if not you'll have to
invent your own purpose or have none at
all
strangely of all the things I know about
you
I don't know what you believe you have
to decide Morgan
who are you what the [ __ ]
holy [ __ ]
look at that
I'm at like the top of the world right
now like at all I don't want to alarm
you but has been a launch from the arcus
platform the Board of Directors has
caught wind of the situation here
suppose it was inevitable this
microphone that's why it's important we
and quickly missive Li don't try to take
this on my house Morgan okay well let us
know what the [ __ ] that is actually over
that [ __ ]
where am I where am I
this is really weird
is this Transtar
here [ __ ] remix in there
lolly the big way are you approaching
the crew completes if so this is a
sentimental request but my collection
the gallery of photos the others used to
laugh at each picture is a decryption
key to a set of neural data connectors
the guests who came to the station among
them like the tearling is there now we
can't let those skills be lost so this
little bit please Morgan you can I will
be great I'm sending you an audio file
that will open this safe in my roof you
can play with your transcribe
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
something crazy okay
okay there is a lot of [ __ ] going on
right now power plant [ __ ] is the cook
crew quarters [ __ ] that [ __ ]
nice right there
[Music]
[ __ ] okay
all right where do you call that
[ __ ] great
okay I guess just suck my life right
[Music]
look at OSI [ __ ] coral no dinner
what is that
the you family cause much trouble on
earth now they play with the Stars and
expect not to burn I wondered why you
opened us to the chamber make us see our
eyes sharp gray threat congressman you
surround yourself with machines with
things they cannot give you safe they
will eat you as well after they eat you
maybe take yourself become mu judge
shuttle axis
[ __ ] you kill me response conditions
okay I gotta get these cool note
[ __ ] okay
[Music]
how do I [ __ ] get to the corner
you [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ] this was all over play
vital signs critical how can I eat these
veggie black skirt I'm [ __ ] dead
[Music]
okay back to the call that
okay [ __ ] it I'm getting it now they
play with my you opened us to a chamber
[ __ ] that there's again matches
puzzle response your conditions the you
channel it caused much trouble on earth
now they play with the Stars and expect
not to burn I wondered why you opened us
to a chamber make us see our right
raisered hungry you surround yourself
with machines were things make you not
keep you safe they will eat you as well
after they eat you maybe I take you
become mu get shuttle access shut
by give all their victims ground Rose on
the right track is the kind of neural
future die lactic like activity up and
down the length of it like it's
communicating oh yes my champion one
more to go you can handle this our
father warned me not to drink so much of
the company's future on your ideas
I was right to ignore him we're a good
team
okay here is bash tonight [ __ ] see
like a food container right here okay
well offensive space here we go
okay so yeah you're [ __ ] eat and read
to a business he's talking food okay
well what's the [ __ ]
oh there it is yeah yeah basket fly away
fly away
[ __ ] I've gone for the other side
they did not pay me enough for the chef
that is sign
that's that
where is that where's the carload [ __ ]
I'm so dirty
oh great don't [ __ ]
ah [ __ ]
[Music]
how the [ __ ] do I get there
does anyone know I just stuck around
deck up there okay
what else was around here
yeah I live watch right okay
that was [ __ ] awful hazard response
here innocence
clap time
all right
it's at now
Harris Lally
you
clock
carefree no nothing that interferes with
memory formation search complete
excellent work all that's left is
integrating the day after you upload it
are the telephone just to scan summary
about worry what is missile kinda your
own different Wyatt meld into the coral
Christ Morgan came back to my office we
have to get your data upload it out
hurry
oh [ __ ] we gonna damn ah [ __ ] what the
[ __ ] was that
our battle Sarge
critical ow ow ow
now-now-now
holy [ __ ] okay what is that now y'all
left watch it out
cool oh shut it was in the saying that
was actually insane uh okay stress on
this game the stress of this game got
sent to me here's my terminal to upload
the data
I'll get it integrated into the
fabrication plan for the new null wave
device as fast as possible and be
careful
the typhoon will begin to sense our
intent to harm the coral they're going
to come after you unless something for
your my desk that should help not anger
so the car okay yeah
Lauren transfers holding my office I am
someone
this is commander Walter dull the
Transtar Board of Directors has
authorized me to take full command of
palace 1 effective immediately all
employment has now report to the shuttle
bay for evacuation those of you unable
to comply transmit an SOS and my team of
rescue operators were located one last
thing Alex and Morgan you have been
relieved of their positions do not
consent to the request for assistance in
any way Val out well our can't stall
your day has this fracture protection
system
what's one okay Jesus
I need to [ __ ] help that's what I
need
John okay a couple of things stess
[ __ ] rely and EMP get [ __ ] ready
do I have any suit things transfers
holding something for someone
this is commander Waldo the transpire
actors has authorized me to take full
command of Talos one effective
immediately all employees must now
report to the shuttle bay for evacuation
those of you unable to comply transmit
an SOS and my team of rescue operators
will locate you
one last thing Alex and Morgan you have
been relieved of their positions do not
consent to their requests or a system in
any way dull out
well our top is Dolph Jordi has this
horrible Vinterberg major system of what
tell us one fine contingency in place
but a small foolish part of may believe
they wouldn't use them against their own
flesh and blood
regardless we're not getting this coral
data through until we do something about
it
I don't like it but you're gonna have to
get into this convention
see if you can locate his access point
in cut him off
okay thank you you [ __ ] ate some
blueberries pretend this isn't happening
coming
all right now right now
one last thing Alex and more [ __ ]
I need a resigner in remains of their
positions do not consent to their
requests for a fish game in any way dull
out here like that [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
one last thing Alex and Morgan you have
been relieved of their positions do not
consent to their requests or a sustained
in any way bailout
come on come on open the door
[Music]
Oh
I don't even know where the [ __ ] I'm
going get the arming key why lockdown
install your D has this works into every
major system of or tell us what to admit
I'm disappointed with our parents and
you really had a contingency in place
but a small foolish part of me believed
they wouldn't use him against their own
flesh and blood
regardless we're not getting this coral
data through until we do something about
it
come on come on I don't like it but
you're gonna have to get into his
command shuttle yeah see if you can
locate his access point in cut him off
okay
how do I get the [ __ ] army K
okay come on jay says Alex with that
bucket here we know that what the [ __ ]
is a doll we'll know you're coming
personnel are outfitted with tracking
bracelets I have no doubt his arms
already on their way to rescue you those
bracelets are issued removed in deep
storage worth investigating if you want
to fly under the radar take it okay
the [ __ ] is that noise like I am
okay let me sing for one hot second
camara cellos that way
[ __ ] I do not now Muto [ __ ] go for
okay [ __ ] it deep storage it's right
there
I might as well just [ __ ] deactivate
it operator deployments resuming look I
heard the announcement no no I will not
give you up you were there for me I am
here for you if you'll indulge me I have
a proposal that could get us off Talos
one without any more bloodshed just
don't harm the land we got a chance to
speak in person I think that's bad
I'll shut my box operator ready to
deploy please stand clear about
okay so these military operators are now
trying to account it that's fine
and at some point you just kind of get
used to it in life okay please don't be
human slowly is Dena
and where you got here hold like the
title well on the word your brother he
likes a microphone spotlight diner
things radiation toxicity Windows
learning level zero learning are out you
play Cara new session air at the fashion
attic the wires and [ __ ] in the
walls are you trying to fix the mess
you've made
or just get away I pride myself feeling
prepared for the worst but this this is
truly a masterpiece what you should be
proud yes I can answer
okay so [ __ ] um
Jesus Christ that Lobby is [ __ ] you
right what I don't even know where the
[ __ ] I'm going personal workstation it's
got to be it's got to be in here
Cosette oh um new setup and find out
what's his face
okay well I can't find that guy [ __ ]
where some Grant Lockwood not here not
here not here
[Music]
not here here we go
[Music]
okay okay so [ __ ] [ __ ] I gotta meet him
in lobby that I guess now [ __ ] I have to
find a workday level all your usual
horsemen
that's Matthew Morgan oh thank god I've
just been going down the contact list
hopeless money with it let him [ __ ]
[ __ ] promising I came up here to look
for supplies
I think I broke my arm when that
blackout hit Mel brother [ __ ] why do
some editing sake door really help [ __ ]
that [ __ ]
hello are you here for my three brothers
indicator okay
I'm in deep storage
so this isn't the place today okay
area map [ __ ] hello nice get me okay
how do I do this personal tracking where
expect should enter my number
Jack pending storage zero nine one three
enemy upstairs my mistake okay with the
computer thank you
key marker okay with it where's the
psionic [ __ ] on your visa [ __ ] shagged
out here
[ __ ] eggs
[ __ ] that's am [ __ ] coming
can tell [ __ ] the [ __ ] comic those
[ __ ] [ __ ]
okay anyway um which one is it
here and I'm on three
there yeah
Kevin a brat now I can't see you
your brother won't be so lucky I'm
closing in on him
the [ __ ] can I just do the same thing
man okay
okay what's next thing I do command
shuttle people please - oh [ __ ] oh okay
you know weapons Locker
[ __ ] I need a suit diamond [ __ ]
reload everything looks right [ __ ]
doctor I get to the other side [ __ ]
glass
[ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ]
where does this go where does this go
bridge Oh
oh right okay how do I close it okay
good
and I mean anything else I gotta take
care of what what's up their parents
take their so let's like this okay I did
get a day good coming in here [ __ ]
swing [ __ ] city
can I wait out this a 120mm lock Sophie
madera luck submitted
let me definitely check out my map hey
sonic and [ __ ] it oh [ __ ]
hi I'm not why are nights a day there's
the bridge what's out here that yeah
I just take a look out there take crew
quarters quarters is mm-hmm left okay
I'll let a little more guys bad with may
I hear him thirty seconds so I drink
some caffeine may check my phone
okay I forgot
next come with me
[Applause]
yet okay huh [ __ ] what oh [ __ ]
that's okay I got Taylor's hair to have
the area map security door unlock what's
across something it's not urban in there
I wanna
Oh put this lock let's [ __ ] down oh
[ __ ]
yes oh [ __ ] a lot of [ __ ] things we
got to do this is why this session takes
like 30 years squad this is going to be
a 20-hour episode Ken okay I'm getting a
check this [ __ ] quiet in here
why is it so quiet in here sir
yeah Mayfair closing superficial
injuries nothing a portable medical
[ __ ] [ __ ] oh [ __ ]
ready go let's just walk in here okay I
rec center crew we just open that door
okay now one of these people has like a
legendary gun
we just search it really quick [ __ ] I
have to take a [ __ ] okay I'm coming use
bang a lot of people anything I don't
get why I mean I get money from big
praying okay pray Calvin got let's see
how do I get the call that gun
oh it's artist pistol it's from Cato
marks where's the see also thing
that was the Artemis pistol here we go
okay where we gotta go up enough and
it's captain Jana marks office class
okay okay
with the body in crew quarters
okay fine
okay that's where we got to go I'm not
with the [ __ ] or not Kenny Kenny
head for the bridge
[ __ ] is the bridge rec center cafeteria
fitness center executive suites as a
locked okay okay okay
[ __ ] eggs on the fridge okay was
there something I gotta get in here
you [ __ ] it hard
[Music]
[Music]
where is it
[Music]
[ __ ] worth every penny
a cat blood now yes the lock was key to
the first concerto lightning blade it
was the first time Maya heard him
we were both I felt small in the line of
his skill I can play it now - thanks to
a neuro mod but only in my head
you used to gift me Ramon I copied their
neural scans see the date on my
transcript okay [ __ ] idea of the bridge
[ __ ]
okay okay so get out of it where is it
that way
the birch is over here top spot okay huh
[ __ ] getting crazy
and okay captain body signs bridge
right okay I just [ __ ] away fit all
that where is it where is that okay talk
escape pods over there let's just check
that [ __ ] [ __ ] left looks like a
different set of escape pods than the
last one I want to
make sure everything in here [ __ ] there
is Morgan you we are over now haha
[Music]
[ __ ] [ __ ] okay Allah that's our
let's get shadowing do I have any only
suit [ __ ]
man [ __ ] I just kill like out a [ __ ]
rat just [ __ ] up [ __ ]
[Applause]
fuckin'-a Oh what the [ __ ] [ __ ] [ __ ]
[ __ ]
[Applause]
um I shot a shot have I never been here
I've never been here
we share the marks up there okay good
talking memory Kira
hi really [ __ ] rude for me to check
in all his emails but and I like they're
not in I going to do
he's a [ __ ] lunatic right here
another is where
okay what's over there
what is this please see if it's worth it
whatever is in there slap add a third
here
Oh don't [ __ ] with that
I have one thing safe [ __ ] hilarious
your suits ow ah that's pretty cool
actually so it's not like a good
afternoon talos lunch is served in the
cafeteria from 12:00 to 2:00 p.m. please
refer to the weekly upgrade for today's
menu this is so cool
so if this what that was about but I can
say de
what
fucking-a
holy [ __ ]
okay vacua ssin
okay so let me get this Golden Gun and
we'll end up that [ __ ] they're going to
go back up the stairs yeah [ __ ] yes
a lotta playing come on applying there's
a knock a great guy watch out honey I
[ __ ] never scut never good
okay just the crew now that's deep
starch a snap that's not editing okay
final shot holy [ __ ] okay
it's called nothing I got Jedi marks a
[ __ ] gun
sure
that's what I'm talking about that's a
small talk about let's talk about 1600s
yet I'd say in fact
[Music]
now this is a [ __ ] guy
alright well we're going to end it here
[ __ ] oh no no thanks for watching and
tune in later okay thank you maybe one
day we'll beat this game maybe one day
okay bye